بعد ثمان ساعات فقط من الهدوء الحذر دوت
صفارات الانذار في مستوطنات الغلاف
الاسرائيلي بعد التصعيد في قطاع غزه
والغارات الاسرائيليه المستمره منذ فجر
الثلاثاء والتي اسفرت عن مقتل 25
فلسطينيا بينهم قاده من حركه الجهاد
وسرايا القدس وارتفاع المصابين الى 76
فلسطينيه الفصائل ردت باطلاق مئات
الصواريخ من القطاع اخرها اطلاق سته قذائف
هاون على المستوطنات بحسب اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي تصعيد تعثرت معه المساعي
المصريه المستمره لوقف اطلاق النار وحول
هذه المساعي افادت وسائل اعلام فلسطينيه
بان وفد من حركه الجهاد توجه الى القاهره
قادمه من تركيا لبحث التهدئه وتعثرت جهود
وقف النار سيما بعد اغتيال اسرائيل
للقيادي في سرايا القدس علي غالي المسؤول
عن الوحده الصاروخيه في عمليه مشتركه لجيش
الدفاع وجهاز الشابات جنوب غزه في غارات
اسفرت عن مقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين بينهم
قيادي في سرايا القدس الجناح المسلح لحركه
الجهاد ويبدو ان الامور مفتوحه على مزيد
من التصعيد سيما بعد تهديدات الاسرائيليه
باستمرار الهجوم على القطاع وهذا ما اكد
عليه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو في اخر تصريح له تزامنا مع
الغارات الاخيره بينما توعدت حركه الجهاد
بان الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه لن تمر مرور
الكرام وان جميع الخيارات مطروحه
[موسيقى]
ومن حدود قطاع غزه تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه لانك الغاسلين مرحبا بك معي في
هذه ان النشره سؤال عن
الاوضاع الامنيه في الحدود هناك ايضا يعني
الحديث عن رشقات جديده من الصواريخ من
قطاع غزه باتجاه اسرائيل كيف هي الامور
ميدانيا من حول الكيلان
اهلا بك صحيح فعليا بعد هدوء استمر لمده
ثمان ساعات منذ ساعه الثانيه في منتصف
الليل حتى الساعه الثامنه وعشرين دقيقه
صباح اليوم كان هناك هدوء تام في قطاع غزه
وايضا لم يتم اطلاق الصواريخ الى قطاع غزه
او الى مستوطنات الغلاف او حتى الى مناطق
اخرى في اسرائيل ولكن منذ صباح اليوم منذ
تحديدا ساعه تقريبا كان هناك ثلاثه رشقات
اطلقت من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه من قطاع
غزه نحو المستوطنات غلاف غزه هنا ايضا
يعني
السفارات الانذار كانت تدوي في مناطق هنا
مختلفه في المستوطنات ايضا الملاجئ ما
زالت مفتوحه لدى المستوطنين والاسرائيليين
ايضا تحدثنا عن 8,000 مستوطن ومستوطنه
خرجوا من مستوطناتهم او من منازلهم في
المستوطنات هنا في غلاف غزه وتوجهوا الى
مدن يعني قريبه او اكثر امانا حسب يتم
وصفها حتى الان هم يعني لم يعودوا الى
منازلهم والى المستوطنات هنا القريبه من
الحدود والملاجئ ايضا ما زالت مفتوحه في
الجبهه الشماليه تخوفا من تدخل ايضا
الجبهه الشماليه والصعيد اكبر من محتمل
حتى اللحظه هناك يعني هدوء يعني حذر حسب
ما يتم وصفه ولكن ايضا نستطيع سماع
الطائرات المراقبه والتي يصفها
الفلسطينيين بطائرات او يسموها بطائرات
الزنانه بسبب صوتها العالي جدا وحتى
اللحظه هذا هو المشهد هنا من الحدود مع
قطاع غزه القبه الحديديه هل تعاملت مع هذه
الرشقات الصاروخيه التي يعني اطلقت للمره
الثالثه وفي دفعتها الثالثه باتجاه
اسرائيل لانا
صحيح القبه الحديديه ايضا قامت باسقاط
معظم الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه لكن
حاليا الحديث الاهم هو يدور حول التهدئه
الممكن ان تكون ربما في اليوم او غدا ولكن
يعني قيادي في الجناح السياسي لحركه حماس
ايضا توجه الى القاهره صباح اليوم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات